foreign
there's zero circumstances in which I'd
settle there's zero circumstances in
which I'll quit and I have the resources
to go all the way and so do they so this
is going to be a battle and we're gonna
have a lot of fun and I'm gonna win
the person to think about the impact
s that either one of these cases would
have into our communities is devastating
my name is Eric person I'm the owner of
Maverick gaming which owns the 31
casinos across Washington Nevada and
Colorado
foreign
state in a city called Hoquiam
Washington it was a very small town but
very poor
um I spent my first 18 years of my life
here before I went out to college
eventually went to Georgetown law what
game is all I've ever wanted to do in
fact it's really the only jobs I've ever
had I ultimately for Maverick gaming
which is named after my son so Maverick
gaming owns 23 car rooms in the state of
Washington we have around half the card
rooms in the whole state neighborhood
card rooms typically employed somewhere
between 75 and 150 people they're
they're based in a lot of
residential areas or small Commercial
Business areas but there is a
neighborhood Cheers Bar in the state of
Washington the car rooms are capped at
15 tables per property so that's why
these properties end up being much
smaller and because of tribal compacts
you know they don't have slot machines
in the state of Washington whereas we
would in Nevada and Colorado that's the
main differences
[Music]
New Jersey sued and and sports betting
became legal not just in a couple States
but but throughout this country should
the governors allow elect to allow it
and So eventually the through the
legislature the state of Washington
elected to allow sports betting and
unfortunately they did to the exclusion
of commercial gaming interests and a lot
of Monopoly the tribal properties
the powers that be and the legislature
said no we're going to give that
exclusively to the tribes they have a
lot of uh of the clout in our
legislature and they were able to stop
that bill from moving forward they
probably have 95 percent or more of the
gaming in our state we're the plaintiffs
suing the state of Washington and we're
asking to be included with sports
betting we think it's great that the
tribes have sports betting and we have
no issue with that at all we just know
that our businesses are not thriving
there used to be over 100 car rooms in
the state of Washington now there's less
than 45 and every time you give a right
to a competitor in some ways you exclude
the person who is trying to compete and
so what that means is on a Saturday or
Sunday when football is going one less
room to reason to be in a card room one
more reason to be in a tribal facility
and we don't think that's fair we're at
the ninth circuit and someone's going to
win and someone's going to lose and
whoever loses is going to appeal and
ultimately you think we're going to get
standing in the Supreme Court because
we're going to create a split in
decisions across the various circuit
courts and we believe when we get the
Supreme Court we're going to win
my name is Rebecca George I am a member
of the poor Campbell School Island tribe
and come from the Suquamish people and
I'm the executive director of weiga we
call it the Washington Indian gaming
Association in Washington we have really
focused gambling dollars to benefit the
people of Washington and primarily have
only authorized gambling under under the
terms of government gaming 100 of the
doll the proceeds from the gambling
activity both at the state lottery and
for the tribal gaming
go to fund essential government services
[Music]
with the Inception of Indian gaming we
start to see the numbers ticking in the
right direction for our people not only
our people but the entire surrounding
Community awful often in these very poor
rural areas right we're talking about
education rates and Health Care rates
that are finally moving in the right
direction and if you overlay that mat
with the Inception of Indian gaming as
we currently know it you'll see that
Indian gaming is doing what it intended
to do and that is to help pull people
out of poverty and we have a corporation
Maverick gaming who has come into
Washington and tried to uproot that
entire system that is working to the
benefit of the people of Washington
I think that that is
um a disingenuous
to say that this is about sports betting
with sports betting being less than one
percent of the bottom line for gambling
dollars
there is a bigger effort at play here
are you hoping that at some point
no this is about sports betting you know
and um
the reason we filed litigation is
because we don't believe that the tribe
should have sports betting at the
exclusion of commercial card room
interests anything more than that is
just too much of a reach it's just too
ambitious it's not it's not our focus at
all
foreign
[Music]
you know even his own tribe has come out
against what he is doing talking about
then the implications that they would
have
uh in in show Water Bay well I'm a
member of the Stillwater Beach ride and
so you know I think that's more
theatrics that's being done it's not
random and it certainly wasn't just
something that happened it's not awkward
for me it should be awkward for them
they're the ones that should be
embarrassed
foreign
with the Indian Child Welfare suit is
this is an attack on tribal sovereignty
this is trying to make a mockery of the
Indian gaming regulatory act and to
think about the arguments that this is
racial discrimination is not only wrong
it's offensive
I think that's ridiculous and they know
that I mean as people like to throw on
adjectives because they sound scary but
at the end of the day the tribes are
sovereign Nations and this is about
sports betting this is about not letting
tribes have Monopoly and sports but in
the state of Washington and allowing
commercial businesses compete and create
the jobs that washingtonians need these
jobs are important and these jobs pay
over seventy five thousand dollars per
year on average to our average employee
and they have great lives and when you
lose half of those businesses that's
about 4 000 people who aren't earning
seventy five thousand dollars plus a
year because they weren't allowed to
have competitive betting limits they
weren't they weren't able to have all
the different forms of gaming that the
tribes enjoy
do I think this lawsuit has a chance I
don't think so
do I think that they will appeal it all
the way to the Supreme Court and that we
will spend a lot of money fighting it
yes and to think about the amount of
money that's going into having to defend
this position is sickening right knowing
where that money could be going to
education and health care and saving
salmon and all of the things that tribal
governments really care about
I think it's unfortunate
[Music]